in Wisconsin you've got government
employees getting enormous ly generous
pensions and contributing nothing
towards it and so they elect their own
boss and then the manager and the unions
both negotiate to take more from the
taxpayers who aren't represented at all
hi I'm Nicholas B with reason TV today
we're talking with James Sherk a senior
policy analyst at the Heritage
Foundation
how does collective bargaining work
collective bargaining is basically a
legal monopoly when the government
decides to collectively bargain with
government employees it agrees that it
will only hire those workers and no one
else and that it will negotiate with
those workers for the wages and the
benefits and the other terms of
employment so let's say that you've got
the teachers unions insisting well you
can't fire us no matter how you badly
any of our members perform the
government doesn't have the option of
going to other teachers and saying hey
we'd like to hire you and would like a
provision that if you do a bad job
teaching you'll be laid off and if you
do a good job will give you merit pay
they can't do that under collective
bargaining they have to negotiate with
the teachers unions and come to some
sort of agreement over the work rules
and over the the paying benefits does
collective bargaining necessarily mean
higher pay for state workers does it
mean bigger deficits for state
governments North Carolina has a
terrible budget situation with no
collective bargaining rights and then
there are states that have similarly bad
situations with collective bargaining
collective bargaining and the government
pays only part of the state problems
you've got states for the housing bubble
collapsed will that had nothing to do
with the unions one way or the other but
it's it sort their finances so it's by
no means the only problem but it does
contribute significantly in a number of
states in Wisconsin you've got
government employees getting enormous ly
generous pensions and contributing
nothing towards it only pink 6% of their
health care premiums that's primarily
because of the clutter of the unions
both in terms of the bargaining table
and then what they negotiate is
provisions where their members have to
pay dues or get fired and the state
collects them well that gives them
millions of dollars each year that they
spend very heavily on politics electing
their own bosses and so they're they're
essentially negotiating instead of
against a hostile management they elect
their own boss and then the manager and
the unions both negotiate to take more
from the taxpayers who aren't
represented at all so you think it would
be a
situation if in fact the unions had to
collect their dues you know by
themselves as opposed to working through
the employer that's right if you don't
support the union's agenda then you
shouldn't have to pay and these dues can
be pretty expensive Milwaukee Teachers
Association you have to pay a thousand
dollars a year in these union dues the
divergence between what public sector
workers are getting in terms of benefits
and private sector workers is that
driving a lot of the desire to pull
things back into equilibrium that's
right they have to make cuts and where
would you rather cut if you've got
people who are getting way above market
wages well that's a much more natural
place to to start making the cuts then
with other groups who are far more
sympathetic and what the unions do
systematically is negotiate for higher
benefits in the private sector for each
$1 you earn in wages you'll get around
25 cents in benefits well for the unions
in Wisconsin for the teachers unions
there that's 74 cents and benefits for
every dollar in pay they're getting and
the reason it happens is because cash
wages are very transparent and obvious
for the voters but when you offer these
very generous benefit packages which
average about $45,000 a year for the
teachers say in Milwaukee well it's not
as obvious and particularly the pension
benefits and the retiree health benefits
don't get paid until decades down the
road after the contracts being awarded
when the workers retire so the incentive
is always to say alright we'll give you
what you want but we'll do it in the
form of benefits and particularly
retirement benefits and sort of kick the
can down the road don't have to raise
taxes today don't have to cut spending
today wait till tomorrow
Wisconsin for all of the drama there
it's a very heavily Republican
legislature it seems like it's going to
go through but what about in other
states like Indiana Michigan Ohio New
Jersey New York California what's likely
to play out there's some states who are
simply not going to be able to avoid
making cuts to government compensation
California New York Illinois very
liberal states but their budget
situation is just so bad that a lot of
these changes are going to be made there
anyway all right now in some of the the
more swing states you're you've got a
split some of the governors some of the
legislators want to take on the
collective bargaining and fix the the
problem they want to give back finally
voters full control over how their tax
dollars get spent and take this outside
group off the bargaining table have the
election but then when the voters make
their say they don't have to negotiate
over how they want to spend their tax
dollars and they don't give a special
interest that kind of privilege so in
Tennessee you're seeing a move towards
ending collective bargaining with the
teachers unions in Ohio there's a much
weaker bill moving through the
legislature that would end collective
bargaining for the state employees but
leave it for the the local government
employees and so there's a number of
states that will go down that route but
at the same time the unions the real
purpose of the protests in Wisconsin is
not trying to win there they know
they're not going to win there the
purpose is to discourage other governors
from taking down going down that same
path and from taking those same steps
so you're seeing governor's like
corporate of Pennsylvania Rick Snyder in
Michigan Rick Scott in Florida saying
well no no will will ask for cuts in in
pay but we're not going to address the
the the fundamental problem of
collective bargaining James Sherk a
senior policy analyst at the Heritage
Foundation thanks very much for talking
to Reason TV I'm Nikolas